Você já parou para pensar que seus
cabelos brancos podem ser um sinal que
seu corpo tá te protegendo?
Pois é, pesquisadores da Universidade de
Tóquio descobriram que o mesmo processo
que faz o cabelo ficar branco pode
ajudar a prevenir o câncer. Quando as
células que produzem o pigmento no
cabelo sofrem algum dano no DNA, o corpo
prefere eliminar essas células. Isso faz
com que o fio perca a cor. Mas olha que
interessante, esse mecanismo é uma forma
de defesa natural para impedir que essas
células danificadas se tornem
cancerígenas. É como se o corpo
dissesse: "Melhor ficar grisado do que
desenvolver um tumor". O estudo foi
feito em Camundongos e mostra que esse
sistema funciona bem até certo ponto,
mas se houver muita exposição radiação,
toxinas químicas ou luz solar em
excesso, ele pode falhar, aumentando o
risco de câncer de pele. Então, na
próxima vez que aparecer aquele fio
branco, lembre-se, talvez ele seja um
sinal de que seu corpo tá fazendo
exatamente o que deveria te protegendo.